you might think there are many things
that I can't do because I cannot see
let's lovely true actually
I just needed to have a bit of a help to
come up to the stage but there is also a
lot that I can do this is me
rock climbing was the first time
actually I love sports and I can play
many sports like swimming skiing skating
scuba diving running and so on but there
is one limitation somebody needs to help
me I want to be independent I lost my
sight at the age of 40 in a swimming
pool accident I was an active
independent teenager and suddenly I
became blind the hardest thing for me
was losing my independence things that
until then seemed as simple became
almost impossible to do arrow for
example one of my challenges was
textbooks back then there were no
personal computers no internet no
smartphones so I had asked one of my two
brothers to read me textbooks and I had
to create my own books in Braille
can you imagine of course my brothers
were not happy about it
and later I noticed they were not there
whenever I needed them I think they
tried to stay away from me I don't blame
them I really wanted to be freed from
relying on someone that became my strong
desire to ignite innovation jump ahead
to mid-1980s I got to know cutting-edge
technologies and I thought to myself
how come there is no computer
technologies to create books in Braille
these amazing technologies must be able
to also help people with limitations
like myself that's the moment my
innovation journey began I started
developing digital technologies such as
digital Braille editor digital Braille
dictionary and a digital Braille library
network today every student who is
visually impaired can read textbooks by
using personal computers and mobile
devices in Braille or in boys this may
not surprise you since everyone now has
districts in the tablets in 2015 but
Brady went digital
many years before digital books already
in the late 1980s almost 30 years ago
strong and specific needs of the blind
people made this opportunity to create
digital books way back then and this is
actually not the first time this
happened because history shows us
accessibility ignites innovation the
telephone was invented while developing
a communication tool for
hearing-impaired people some keyboards
were also embedded to help people with
disabilities now I'm going to give you
another example from my own life in the
90s people around me started talking
about the internet and web browsing I
remember the first time I went on the
web I was astonished I could access
newspapers at any time and every day I
could even search for any information by
myself I desperately wanted to help the
blind people have access to the Internet
and I found ways to render the web into
synthetized
boys with drama
pretty simplified the user interface
this led me to develop the home page
reader
in 1997 first in Japanese and later
translated into 11 languages when I
developed the home page video
I got many comments from users well that
I strongly remember said for me the
Internet is the small window to the
world it was a revolutionary moment for
the blind the cyber world became
accessible and this technology that we
created for the blind has many uses way
beyond what I imagined it can help
drivers listen to their emails
or it can help you listen to recipe you
are cooking today I'm more independent
but it is still not enough for example
when I approach the stage just now I
needed assistance my goal is to come up
here
independently and not just here my goal
is to be able to travel and do things
that are simple to you ok now let me
show you the latest technologies and
this is a smartphone app that our we're
working on 51 feet to the door and keep
straight
take the two doors to go out the doors
on your right nick is approaching looks
so happy oh hi Nick
oh man going UNIX so happy oh well my
paper just got accepted oh that's great
congratulations Thanks
wait uh how'd you know it was me and
then I look happy all right
hi he is not talking to you but on his
phone
potato chips
dark chocolate with elements you gain
five pounds since yesterday please take
a instead of chocolate approaching your
right now thank you
so now the up navigates me
by analyzing vehicle signals and
smartphone sensors and permit me to move
around indoor and outdoor environment
all by myself but a computer vision part
you know that showed who is approaching
in which mood we are still working on
that part and recognizing facial
expressions is very important for me to
be social so now the huge ins of
technologies are ready to help me see
the real world we call this cognitive
assistance it understands our
surrounding world and responds to me in
boys or sends vibrations to my fingers
cognitive assistant will augment missing
or weakened abilities in other words
about five senses this technology is
only in an early stage but eventually I
will be able to find a classroom on
campus enjoy window shopping or find a
nice restaurant while walking along the
street it will be amazing if I can find
you on the street before you notice me
it will become my best body and yours so
this really is a great challenge it is a
challenge that needs collaboration which
is why we are creating an open community
to accelerate research activities just
this morning we announced to open source
fundamental technologies you just saw in
the video
the frontier is a real world the blind
community is exporting this technical
frontier and the path finder I hope to
work with you to explore the new era and
the next time that I'm on this stage
through technology and innovation I'll
be able to walk up here all by myself
thank you so much